bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france leur confinement
on imagine un frein supplémentaire à la
reconstruction du liban
bonjour oui on est déjà très impacté par
la crise économique le confinement ça la
crise économique commençait en 2019 le
confinement ensuite maintenant
l'explosion donc c'est crise après crise
parce que le liban on le rappelle la
traverse donc une crise multiple est
allé à la fois économiques financières
sociales sanitaires on l'a dit avec
cette crise ducobu 19
comment le pays peut s'en sortir pour le
moment ils sont seuls une aide
internationale
sur le plan économique pour y permettre
d'améliorer les choses
il n'y a plus d'argent pour financer et
la crise des problèmes socio économiques
et la reconstruction etc etc
malo et les prévisions sont qui ont
totalement sont pessimistes ou passent
avant l'explosion de navettes des
estimations de 13 à 14% de récession
économique avec maintenant ce qui se
passe on est à -24%
selon certaines banques d'affaires donc
l'aide internationale est nécessaire
la question qui se pose maintenant est
est ce que la classe politique va
accepter les réformes qui sont
nécessaires à la débloquer parce qu'on
le rappelle plus de 252 millions
seraient nécessaires à la reconstruction
du pays mais le fmi elle reste formel
pas des deux liban sans réforme les
négociations sont au point mort depuis
le mois de mai quelles sont les attentes
du fmi et comment est ce que vous voyez
l'évolution de la situation dans un pays
et qui n'a plus le gouvernement
d'abord je me permet de corriger un truc
c'est 250 millions d'êtres humanitaires
immédiats des suites de l'explosion du
port de beyrouth mais en fait les
besoins du liban sont destinés à
plusieurs milliards de dollars on a une
part de 10 à 15 milliards de dollars 2
pour financer la reconstruction déjà des
choses qui ont été endommagés par le par
l'explosion on parle ensuite pour le
plan de relance du fmi ont le liban
demande une aide de 10 milliards de
dollars et à cela s'ajoutent les 11
milliards de dollars d aide
internationale qui était premier dans le
cadre de la conférence dead de paris
d'avril 2018 donc les chiffres c'est
beaucoup plus important que les 250
millions de dollars d'être humanitaire
immédiate
comment le pays maintenant peut s'en
sortir
quelles sont les conditions de la
famille les conditions sont claires un
cd réforme économique notamment dans le
secteur de l'énergie qui est ce qu'il ya
un gouffre l'état subventionne à peu
près pour deux milliards de dollars
l'achat de fioul pour les centrales
électriques et malgré tout ça le liban
souffre de pénuries quotidiennes qui
sont de plus en plus importante
on à l'audit de la banque centrale qui
doit déboucher sur une sur le chiffrage
du secteur du secteur financier
donc ces dates sont estimés pour le fmi
et pour le gouvernement à plusieurs
dizaines de milliards de dollars
et là il ya une controverse entre
secteur bancaire qui essaie de diminuer
ce chiffrage et le gouvernement pour le
pour le secteur pour le moment le fmi
considère que le chiffrage preset de
gouvernements précédents qui à peu près
à 63 milliards de dollars est plus
correct que ceux de 80 ans pendant 2
milliards de dollars est plus correct
que ce soit du de l'association des
banques du liban
troisièmement il ya maintenant un autre
paramètre qui devrait aussi rentré en
jeu c'est que la population demande des
réformes politiques et le départ de la
classe politique notamment et ça
personne ne l'évoquent
mais le retour de la confiance pour
faire marcher le système économique
impose aussi de prendre en compte ce
paramètre
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de répondre à nos questions ce
matin françois el bacha économistes
c'est le co fondateur de linda news